okay so the very last assignment please
go to this unofficial acts render scene
repository there is also a link below it
that shows you how the individual scenes
look like please choose a scene and
render it with an unbiased method
several times and merge the results
together I hope that you remember from
the previous lecture how you can merge
together individual runs of unbiased
algorithms and hopefully get something
better than the individual images do it
with other algorithms both biased and
unbiased algorithms I've also uploaded
the settings file to help you with these
different algorithms and see what
happens I don't want to spoil the fun
but obviously we expect a given class of
algorithms to perform well in this
regard and some of them not so much also
try to experiment with photo mapping
type algorithms place your observations
in the observations dot txt file tell me
what kind of algorithm worked where what
are the failure cases and why and is
this what you have expected or did you
get something different remember when we
were doing mathematics in the very first
lectures we first always listed our
expectations and then after we got the
results we discussed whether reality was
in line with our expectations or not
this is a really good methodology so
please do it all the time there will be
a rendering competition afterwards where
a really prestigious international
committee will judge your work and there
are lots of valuable prizes we will get
three tickets to the next year's ceg see
conference and pixel Vienna so that's a
total of six free conference tickets for
you I'm also holding a talk at the CJC
so I would be more than excited to meet
you there so the cgc is the central
european games conference this is big
salt Vienna their flyer from last year
so after you handed in your work you may
be getting one of the three prizes the
third prizes plus half of a grade on the
exam and this provided that you would
already pass the course the second prize
is plus one grade on the exam and
first prize is perhaps this is the
official description perhaps in even
greater influence on the exam grade if
you don't really have artistic veins or
you would like to do some programming
assignment instead of deluxe render
scene contest you're free to do that
please contact me let's cook up a
realistic and exciting problem for you
that you can solve so don't just start
pounding away at your keyboard and doing
something please write to me so we can
discuss what you're exactly going to do
and if you do that you're going to be
subject to the very same price okay so
what about the rendering contest the
contest theme this year is going to be
fluids it's great because we have a
great fluid simulator in blender you
have to create a scene and handing
converged images not noisy converged
images of this scene okay so what is the
list of things that you need to hand in
we would like to get the lux render
scene please copy every asset every
texture every mesh everything that you
have in the scene in this luxe render
seem directory that you give to us so we
can run it ourselves we need also like I
said a completely noise-free rendered
image we would also need the blend file
or if you're using a different model or
program you're absolutely free to use
that please be my guest just please send
us the project file and also send us one
text file with a few lines on what you
try to accomplish and why you think that
your work is the greatest work ever
created by humanity third-party sources
for meshes are fine but you have to give
credit to the people who created it
important we also asked for a halfway
progress report what does it mean there
will be a final deadline for the
assignment and halfway through that
there will be another deadline where I
expect you to send me an email with the
very same subject as the assignment
itself you send me one rendered image
which is just a rough a really rough
draft of what you're going to do so I'd
like to see your current progress and at
least one line of text with your plans
what are you exactly trying to
accomplish this we do because we
would like to discourage people from
trying to put together some seen in the
last two days of the assignment and not
have enough time to render it correctly
or to develop it correctly we would just
like to make sure that you are on time
and please check the course website to
see what exactly are the deadlines for
this ok so who will be on the committee
first jean-philippe Grimaldi he is the
head developer of luck surrender the
kindest kindest person who has been on
this committee for the third year now
and he is always very excited to see
your work voy de aqui Aras you hopefully
remember the name from before he's the
head of the rendering group of Disney
research 3 and an excellent a truly
excellent researcher me halla damer our
beloved professor who is the head of the
rendering group at our university what
about the programming guys if you don't
want to participate in the rendering
contest that's fine that's perfectly
fine there's two different things that
you can do one do something with lux
render we have for instance a bug
tracker where people are asking for
features and people are also asking for
bugs to be fixed if you are interested
in this then please take a look and if
you commit something that is useful then
you will be subject to a first prize now
note that the first price can be won by
multiple people if you cross a given
threshold with the quality of your work
then you will be subjected to the first
price and there may be many of you who
do when there's also the small paint
line where you can improve small paint
by practically anything you can add
bi-directional path tracing multiple
important sampling photo mapping
whatever you have in mind but before you
decide on anything contact me last
year's theme was volumetric caustics I
think that's an amazing theme but this
year this is not what we're going to be
interested in what we're going to be
interested in is fluid simulations this
scene was created in blender so you can
do sophisticated simulations like this
and even much more sophisticated than
this I have prepared some blender fluid
simulation tutorials for you so please
take a look and please make sure that
you
your simulation is the very least 300
cube and also an example video to set
the tone this is taken from the real
flow reel from last year it is
absolutely amazing make sure to take a
look and the subject of the email that
we're looking for is the very same you
only need to increment the number of the
assignment and that's it it's been a
wonderful journey for me so thanks for
tuning in I was trying my very best to
teach you the intricacies of light
transport and I hope that now you indeed
see the world differently I got some
student feedback from many of you and I
got the kindest of words so thank you
very much I'm really grateful and if you
are watching this through the internet
then we have a comment section let us
know if you like the course so thank you
very much and despite the fact that it
seems that the course ends here we have
a lecture from before that we haven't
published yet there will be some more
videos with Thomas who teaches you how
to compute subsurface scattering so one
more time thank you very much and it's
been a wonderful journey thanks I'll see
you later